hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades Wow this run-through of
Resident Evil 2 has been so much fun
and it looks like we're almost near the
end we're getting there slowly we've
just beaten William Birkin for a second
time and now we are going to free Hader
let's just enjoy this lovely touching
moment you know it's gonna be nice oh
are you getting worried there for a
second I can't get it out I don't know
if I should just do it I can't walk like
this okay oh it's kind of like that
didn't she
I can do it myself just relax okay
so what do we do now get yourself out of
here while you still can
I'm not just gonna leave you not like
this you don't understand
the situations worse than I thought
you're not getting rid of me that easy
you protected me now it's my turn
realize we were keeping score 2-1 I'm
keeping score rookie helps get up a
gangster limp you ready for it
yeah true gangster you wanna help we
have to get to the nest that's to the
nest umbrellas lab right beneath us net
let it slip that's where the virus
samples are you up for this
I think I could fit in my schedule what
was the nest called in the films you got
work to do
yes ma'am I think it was the hive out of
interest does anybody like the Resident
Evil films capable Carl take us down to
nest the wristbands are ticket to ride
nice where'd you get that
borrowed it anyway we're almost there
vada you need to acknowledge all the
hard work we've done for you like this
this story walked through this took us
hours stuck we have to find chess pieces
you're not bothered are you you really
don't care about our hard work now
you've got to you know let me carry it
so she has a wound in her leg and she's
wearing stilettos and a tight dress how
is she doing this
it looks superhuman wheelage it just
gonna walk all the way there nice and
slowly that should take us where we need
to go let's get on the super [ __ ] it's
in the original Resident Evil 2 when
they were on this tram
that's when William Birkin started to
smash through the roof and the walls
we've already had that before the last
battle which I thought was a good good
switch man that felt good
this [ __ ] is vamper nest do not exit
until the final destination
know what I was thinking I can't wait
for the FBI to raid umbrella
headquarters and take those bastards to
justice you really think she's from the
FBI
to be clear you're not working in
official capacity never she this is a
federal case once we get the g-virus I'm
back on my own hey Leon trust me he'll
know do you trust me trust me yeah
honestly if I didn't you'd probably be
dead right I thought I might need your
help and I was right if you can secure
the g-virus I can make sure what
happened in Raccoon City never happens
again yeah you said it yourself this is
a federal case I don't be sorry
look at me I'm a liability now I'm gonna
finish this case you're the last hope my
god I'm not just gonna leave you here
and what if you're attacked what if you
need help
oh yeah that's how she gets her own way
I'll be fine
don't worry about me
I got to see this through and I want to
see you again the inside fighter she
knows all the tricks go please we don't
have much time
here take this friendship bracelet ok
best points forever Leon County onion I
know and he likes that okay we have a
wristband so this must be like
electrical door or we have to carry it
damn Daniel
I like that he is actually a bit dirty
you know he's not he doesn't have that
magic uniform where everything is dirt
resistant so where's next into nest okay
door open can we come in oh okay another
door
door open can we come in oh okay
no another dog
oh and now I'm back on edge again there
was a whole five minutes where I felt
completely fine cheers boss so at least
it's brighter here okay I wonder where
the g-virus is not from room
ah so mr. Wayne Lee you're still there
and we probably need your friendship
bracelet you thought I was going to save
then didn't you you were wrong I have no
idea what I need to take ID wristbands
level one is visitor which we are level
two was general what was level three
senior Sequoia day
shotgun shells just laying around so
vistas can pick them up my kind of place
we have a map
Oh beyond this point yes must refrain
from injuring right we need to find
wanly and get his wristband off his cops
or his rotting living dead flesh Oh back
to darkness the music is so good in this
game okay
please be only one wonder can you hear
any more oh hey lost right those two
plane with each other those two were
you're too close I'm stuck if you just
keeps coughing love it's gonna walk
around
AHA never gets old
never gets old the shot to the face in
joining the party over there are you
coming over to see me
the hell that was loud okay you enjoy
your little um soiree I've got air vents
to crawl through and they really this
big by the way I always thought they
were like die hard if you've watched die
hard whether just crawling space they've
even got a McDonald's I'm sorry Wow
special sauce gunpowder waffles oh yeah
just a random Rambo knife in the kitchen
oh you legit scared me then fella
imagine going through that door and
having him just jump at you we got look
we got damn lucky here he is right it's
gonna get these chocolate shells first
and I'll be with you Wayne for a new
mechanic moth everyone loves a bit of
moth
a regulator for the flamethrower okay I
guess we're burning things on this stage
Wayne don't wake up Wayne I just need
this car to come in handy and we're good
to go right level two does now our [ __ ]
it's quite soothing so far no jokes
gasps no no like that screamed Denise do
this calculate like this she I need to
stop wasting my bullets making zombies
dance dance dance dongs
your presence is urgently requested by
achieve cartwright in the east area okay
Kenley leave it in without you don't
wake up mr. hunk Special Forces
recording
okay so that's just before they on their
kills West area hi techie techie this is
a nice facility level for that lifts
over to the right is loads are three
number three and so this is on the we
can use now
no jump-scares there what does this
represent we have to freeze something
what clue are you giving us yeah more
herbs hey look a safe point hmm let's
see what the flamethrower does so we're
buying a regulator on it look at that
it's damn good I need some more bullets
for the handgun 25 who's left the cow
Paul out have no idea which I can pick
up on which it just random medications
Droon about oh oh poison ivy
let me guess you've got the level 3 yet
the level 3 card is in your hand
you died with it she this G happened
here time to give a speech yep I
understand
no that is permanent we can't shatter
the glass
Oh God the nightmare begins again let's
see what new type of enemy there is in
here hang on they legs oh yeah great get
down
alright you headshot victim oh okay
you've got a weak spots now the head
doesn't work we're gonna shoot those
things okay yeah we get this so it's
like Resident Evil 4 no I don't like the
music yeah we'll take you thank you
music music makes the world go round
look at embossed in some moves oh he's
raving yeah go on
Thomas engine over what's in here is a
flashbang nice
input code what random guesses I'm just
just in case you can flick it arrow art
air art okay we'll be here all day I'll
stop I'll stop I'll stop right let's go
find the real code
what is this right so we need to kill
the plumb line with this cartridge Roger
Roger what's in the green house
this is gonna be fun we got helping this
another one let's see how I shot one in
the cut running the shin copper one in
the groin and bring the shoulder nice
and calm oh right it looks like an f ru
and an S and a another F remember the
word views like these enemies my words
as Raven didn't
right so we're writing the word fuels
remember the word fuels and we should be
able to remember that the first and last
letters are the same
what else now let's not bother let's
just get this cold in see what happens
so it's like an F shape you shape S
shape and another out shape yeah boy
let's go down the stairs or ladder
[Music]
don't wake up
oh great more sewerage see now the music
stopped I'm even more frightened I want
dead guy to death we did all that life
oh they're all gonna come alive at the
same time no electric hurry we need to
turn the electricity on come on monkey
just gain any dark or no electricity go
stand and deliver we've got a standard
to deliver man the hell up Adam oh we
can run away he's fine
running away my secret weapon in life
right zombies go on offense liquors as
well
there's a magnum due to a zombie's head
so one bullet kill with a magnum yeah
turn off [ __ ] hey I'm confident now
bring it on come on you'll be under over
here Dennis lovely to meet you
here he comes look what I've got [ __ ]
you like that [ __ ] oh oh he's upside
down get down
I am in love with the Magnum the Magnum
is my friend that is how you defeat a
room full of zombies without making any
ridiculous screaming noises yeah I think
we all know it made so many ridiculous
noises why do we need a trophy let's
look on its butt another code s AF fat I
see fee that's what we're gonna remember
this time Sippy let's have a look at
this so it's Murph so we need some sort
of battery receiver few worse battery
receiver II think would you be
yeah we'll take herbs all day I'm just
gyrating as you do anything down there
no we won't engage we'll leave you to
live live be free zombie shouting Blair
ooh
as much as you like zombie lives matter
t-shirt coming soon you [ __ ] [ __ ]
stay down
oh good enclosed space another one I
don't like the shouty ones they scare me
too much what have we got to play with
gotta come I can just put it straight in
the weapon stupid game what I could do
somebody's no they coming back again and
again right so we can't kill anything
down here I get you
we have a signal modulator when we can't
carry that either so we're going to have
to put a knife inside a zombie come on
grab me love hold this now I have space
and I'm a Magnum to the face
I'll take my knife back now thank you
leave that one there pick which one
should I pick up are the bullets and I
reload and then we'll pick up the
modulator dude dude oh no shouldn't have
done that that was stupid
I can't carry the modulator now oh don't
worry though we're at the lobby so I can
just go check all this crap in the crate
and come back for it it's in your head
in your head dead zombie right let's go
use those modulatory things which drugs
a mine and which ones are not right
it was the corridor well the cafeteria
wasn't too that we need to get back to
here's the guy in the bottom dead now
because he walked all the way up it's a
lot of stairs for a zombie did really
well my hearing things now
look at the carnage I did that right how
the hell do we use this
all right the code is Murph let's chuck
it on error so we must have to tweak it
beforehand
[Music]
okay oh great random noises
goodbye rap tune to this
we're on Smurf setting line up goddamnit
line up but there no yes yes one out
just shove it in so she's dead
oh we keep it alright we goes don't wake
up what do we need electricity for I
can't remember there's two dollars to
choose from got that leg in the air oh
good another dark room why aren't you
using your torch
where's my torch oh yeah another woman
just sat there ready to eat my uncle's
messages can i put a hazmat suit on
right so we're looking for somewhere to
put our canister freezer open right you
modulate the crap out what right so we
need some sort of liquid inside it first
yes okay we no no go find the other door
and that will have some sort of machine
which which creates the fluid we need
now which was the other door don't wake
up don't wake up don't wake up don't
wake up don't wake up don't wake up
good to meet you Janine the door was it
north
okay gain/loss wrong way you Egypt let's
go
hell of a skanky leg is it legit
something called the skanky leg because
if there isn't we need to invent that
we've been here
or map that's useful thank you bit
pointless now we needed it like 20
minutes ago
oh don't let me waste bullets
oh I don't by the Rays animation and
you're not gonna wake off.thank sake
right we need to kill the plant so we
need to find the room with the liquid
solution another one great another dead
end
what was the cold was it SIF I think
come on
thank you yeah s I F then fast hi the
right kind of that looks wrong now ice
right drug testing lab is open
let's go test some drugs hello welcome
to Playstation gray denim today testing
some drugs oh great you're gonna wake up
what the hell is up with your head here
we go
use this Philip is it a mini game it's a
mini game okay leave it with me
this may take a while have you seen is
it die hard with a vengeance I think
I've got that one now and then and put
mine there and we sorted did a little
dated
[Music]
right we go back one more time
and hope we can avoid home box no we
can't avoid combat bullets get the hell
down if you wake up now thank you
yeah we definitely need some more
bullets now back to the room all right
Janine stay down don't do region eight
it's not worth it good less slam thine
are we could have we could have got rid
of the trophy oh well we do it later
[Music]
cool
bling he's not getting up fine you stay
down we're going all the way back to the
bridge Janine it's not worth it
you've got so much to live for MA okay
love you bye look at this curry rice by
far my favourite corridor
yeah this section doesn't seem as scary
as the other ones did this reoccurring
little bastard does my head in
yeah that the the mansion mother mansion
the art gallery the police station that
was most definitely the most fearful
area that's what we need fella we're
coming for you Nigel disciplinary Oh
Michael has pronounced disciplinary
Snowdown hi guys put that straight in
cuz we need the space what's that noise
what's that noise what's that noise okay
okay fair enough we're going we're
running we're leaving
hi mate bye mate oh you can reach bar
it's yours forever and ever Amin oh [ __ ]
our new tactic is wait here he batters
everyone go on misdirect hit them all
come on we're partners just for just for
two minutes
right what would Jesus do legite we need
to just need to get back to the first
room again we can get mr. ex to come
down here then we can get back up again
and get through those three Ivy monsters
oh we can try and see if we can loop all
the way around you thought this will
work because we're unlocked to the lobby
didn't we so we can get all the way
around without engaging at all oh except
for in the boss it burns burns burns
Ring of Fire the Ring of Fire
oh I love little baby zombie as well
[Applause]
dead dead dead today dead
did it do the room I go we're doing it
again think before you sink it was a
good system to get out of all that
combat
we are homeward bound absolutely
smashing at this episode a g-sensor
hopefully the G sample
ah please stay dead or more did you beat
us yeah we'll watch this Thank You
Granada nothing nothing nothing
oh great another one of these OSS so
first we examine we operate we go to or
SS and there's piss a bowel until it
works
how do you make it go left like that
like that okay we're getting there
[Music]
hey and then there was light thank you
yeah let's watch this whose perspective
this time you'll come along with us
quietly you think I know you were coming
this is my life's work I'm not handing
over anything we have our orders dr.
Bergin I'll ask you one more time
someone's in trouble
I think he's visited if we had to take
him on
that's correct sir Roger that just the
samples man let's move so those were gee
samples
those were the Gees indeed William
Birkin Xin box I'm sure that's a really
riveting stuff but I believe in privacy
oh this reminds me of is it Resident
Evil 4 where Ashley or Leon is hooked up
to one of these yeah
it rings a bell certainly anything in
the rubbish you go good old plant can't
say no to a plant I want to wear a
hazmat suit thank you very much we're
going to get radiated come on there must
be a way of putting a hazmat suit on
Leon can't be that hard car I guess he
is we're getting blow-dried as well oh
yeah it's like a Michael Jackson video
[Music]
well this looks like a boss room would
you record something from the ceiling
okay maybe not
adda put money on that being a boss
fight area what's in here
they tyrant parts the arm the brain
heart thing no idea where that is of
course the testicles oh that was easy
what does it do you just see what I say
all right now back to ADA
this is gonna be the the 10-minute
explosion thing Larry no self destruct
sequence will begin very soon boss fight
now maybe go through it again
twice that room was so set for a boss
fight
hey William this must be the last time
now I like it it loud not don't get
close love don't get close
please don't want me don't walk there it
Leon it's not dead well I think Leon's
fine but she's gonna get killed any
second on his thing William why his
name's William come on you are dense
your umbrella too you tell me you
weren't involved in this yes but we
never meant for this to happen did tell
me everything right from the start right
from the start I was born a long time
ago
what have you done William what have you
done what have you done I should write
this script so you made this monster we
made the g-virus but we never intended
its finish anyway why literally looking
at you who's gonna have to be right she
survived that she's hardcore
I guess we're facing
are you doing
we end this now
brilliant William shooting you in your
testicle eyes where's your on your back
how do I get the one on the back by this
okay that was easy
finished okay chest chest testicles
gardens of taking so long
we're going to need a lot of bullets
yeah first aid yes please no you could
jump here give me a little bit of
personal space please William twenty
four bullets oh you miss your
opportunity war magic means stuff oh
come on hit your shots get this gun does
nothing this gun is terrible
got lucky down
you can flame through him
yeah yeah 50 normal rounds I don't want
normal rounds you just trashing the
joint hope you're insured
got really lucky that he was about to
kill me right I testicles in his chest
just get all the way he's throwing
like a child
yes good to go
you're gonna have to heal at some point
right
more bullets over here William he's at
the end William a good fight good night
don't you dare wake up and kill me again
all right I definitely saw something to
pick up around here yeah we'll take
those we'll take everything down here
while we move on so a self-destruct
sequence is going to start which is
usually a 10-minute countdown to finish
the last bit of the game in
hi
Jesus that looks bad
feels worse don't believe me talk about
what you said how much I please just
tell me it'll destroy that G simple no
it's evidence it's gone to the FBI
he's so dense trust that [ __ ] it means
Leonie
need about 12-month match are up she's a
mercenary she's gonna sell it G virus is
gonna go to the highest bidder
oh yeah this bullcrap I've only known
her three hours but I believe in her but
gets into the wrong hands
she's popped her clogs
what happened to compassionate Leon he
has left the building
we're it well yeah this is it in the end
the 10-minute subscriber the ten-minute
self-destruct sequence will begin any
second now
ada will probably come on attackers and
go give me the virus I believe she goes
no not in this dress I should have known
that wasn't standard-issue uniform use
the central elevator
right on cue are you put your mega
zapper of course
thanks to limp look at that I was just
thinking about you that makes two of us
mix three of those sweet cheeks
no we make a good team I'm gonna ask you
something ways clear please tell me you
got it I got it
let me verify the G samp let me get the
hell out of here before we do that I ran
into a net
she claims you're not FBI Oh Leon
seriously I could write this script you
just have as I realized as much as I
wanted to trust you yeah just point guns
at each other didn't I really hoped it
wouldn't end up like this
so that's all this was I was just some
pawn to you
yep look I'm just doing my job I'm doing
mine so drop that damn gun I'm taking
you in
hand over the sample Leon I don't want
to hurt you
we have a face-off and you shoot me
right in the backroom vest she's gonna
know she's not for a second I thought
she was oh oh did we shoot her
nope buys a net net has learned to shoot
bye-bye sample
no one gets it stars
Leon forget about me go live your life
hold on go for like the X on the beach
just forget about it forget it I've got
you it's not worth it don't do this
take care of yourself me one nice flat
Oh Leon how are you still alive there
the end is knife there it is ten minutes
to go
please don't be a long live
how much of a badass does he look
although he looks gray
that's her Bynes in a blow up any second
now
it's in about nine minutes maybe
this is quite hard to escape when you've
stuck in a lift for a minute
when we get out of the lift exactly at
nine minutes that's my next guess
5:03 do okay I was pretty spot-on
ah this is this is a resident evil one
of right it feels in the nostalgia is it
Claire bear
Leon you're down here too
yeah the whole place is coming down
listen to me you need to get out fast
yeah there's a way out the train if I
remember rightly we can make it where
are you now
Claire are you still there Leon hate me
I'm you're breaking up
forget about me just get out of here
damn it if we've lost three minutes of
time because of no we've still got nine
minutes okay the music already starts
it's gonna be one heck of a ride
here we go
so who do we think the final boss is
oh no no we don't have time we don't
have time for this we've got to breath
they reach to five we can't afford to do
this but that's not a ladder keep going
we don't need
slide down the edges like a real action
hero Leon that's too nice dole sheets
the [ __ ] joke
around come around come round Leggett
we don't have time zombie places to be
people to kill
awesome oh great we're getting a
chokeslammed
[Music]
right on his shoulder that's just been
shot
keep going
gotta get get seven minutes anything
anything anything anything anything a
joint plug of course we seven minutes so
if we combine that with that combine
that with that drop with this crap off I
don't know why I carried that through
the entire game extra bullets take the
butt plugs here we go what excited
it's really easy we this is our last
episode this is the end
or it means business now
come on six minutes remember we were
talking about what kind of cheeky
growing shop there's the two types of
boss fight is Wonder way you have to
damage them enough and I there's one
which I think this is I think we have to
survive until we get to the bottom of
the lift so I'm going to avoid rather
than engage I could be wrong but I think
this is the right thing to do
eeeh
smaller think he can break them
doing it's going super stale okay so
that's when we shoot him when he when is
doing whatever the hell he's doing is
the dumbest I like your flame art dude
that up feels on edge with this fight
[Music]
okay okay
tomorrow edge now because I'm almost
dead catch that's how we stop him
don't think I can avoid it for five
minutes
I'm starting to second-guess if I was
right to avoid maybe we should have been
engaging
stick with the plan Adam
yes could see
that's gonna be a rocket launcher yes it
is time to blow that [ __ ] up oh
she's alive it was get out of it let me
just get here that's why we had to take
the book plug earlier on so we could fit
this weapon
turn in the game hahaha I always wanted
to see some tyrants lean and bone
structure thanks for your time dude
you're a very good adversary Zomboid
some boys say I loved in my little
friend how did you survive that
Oh perfect timing oh maybe not
we never soft Claire presume she's
driving the Train baby is that it have
we finished resident evil to remake
keep your friendship bracelet forever
and ever our men can't believe I
actually miss her
yeah you've known a three hours
I miss Claire more
going over to the friendship bracelet
where's the train actually going yeah
we made it just like I said we would
that can't be the ending I want more
Claire
goddamnit Capcom but let's be serious
that was [ __ ] great that was damn
sorry to swear I'm Charles want laws
already in this last four or five hours
I really enjoyed that that was Resident
Evil 2 remake from Leon's perspective so
by completing this we should have
Claire's second scenario which is that
just a shorter version of the game with
different little different things like
I'd expect you know where we're on the
train there to be one more boss fight in
that second scenario but I can't say for
certain at this point but I think there
will be but anyway I'm gonna stop
prattling on what did you think
did you enjoy this was it worth doing
something like this in future again I
should I never go back to doing Let's
Plays ever again you choose but I've
enjoyed this and I thank you for
watching if you stayed all the way till
the end I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a bloody pleasure I'll
see you next time